- [Voiceover] All right, in
this video we're talking about
the short answer section of
the AP U.S. history exam.
In the first part of this
video we talked about
the first two sections of this question
which asked for examples of how contact
with Europeans changed
Native American society.
And the three most important
things we talked about
were first that you really
have to pay attention
to the timeline given
to you in the question
because you don't want to give an answer
that's outside of that time frame,
so only talk about the
period from 1492 to 1700.
Nothing after that.
The second thing we
mentioned is that there
could be all sorts of right
answers to this question.
So choose the things that you know best
and feel most qualified to talk about.
And third, if you're stuck,
consider how a certain issue might affect
people differently of different races,
different classes, and different genders.
You might find a new example
when considering those
that will help you answer
a more difficult question.
All right, let's move on to
the last part of this question.
For part C, we're now looking for kind of
a counter example,
a way that Native
Americans resisted changes
brought on by Europeans
in this time period.
Now you might be tempted to talk about
the Ghost Dance,
but remember that the
Ghost Dance wasn't until
the end of the 19th century.
That's the 1880s, 1890s,
so it's way outside the
scope of our time period
here ending at 1700.
So we're thinking back to the early period
of contact, the early colonial period.
So what are some examples of resistance
to change in this time period?
Well, I think an obvious
example would be war.
Many Native Americans went to war against
European invaders.
Some good examples of this
might be King Philip's War
in New England,
or maybe Popé's Rebellion in the West.
Let me give us a little bit
more space to write here.
These are two really specific examples,
and I would recommend that you give
specific examples whenever possible,
even though it's not necessary at times,
but it will show that you really know
what you're talking about.
Another example of resistance might be
going against some of the things we've
talked about earlier.
So labor, for example.
Well, not all Native
Americans were part of
an encomienda system.
Some of them chose to flee.
It's one of the reasons why Europeans
resorted to African
slavery in this time period
because Native Americans
knew the landscape
very well and could get away when someone
tried to enslave them.
You could also talk about
some cultural resistance
to European ways.
For example, refusal to
convert to Christianity.
Many Native Americans were targeted
by missionaries who were
coming to the New World
specifically to convert Native Americans
to Christianity along with
getting very wealthy, of course.
But in many cases Native Americans
outright refused to
convert to Christianity
or they may have incorporated Christianity
into their own previous beliefs.
So any of these are good options.
And I should think two
out of the three of these
are fairly simple.
I think disease and also warfare
are things that are going to come to mind
right away when we think about this early
period of contact.
It's the second example that's
really gonna make you reach,
and for that I recommend this strategy
of considering race, class and gender,
because among one of
them there's definitely
going to be something that is relevant.
So remember, any of
these answers is correct.
You only need to choose
the ones that you know,
and all you need to do
is write one sentence
about each of these options.
Keep yourself short,
simple and to the point.
Answer the question and move on.